before we get into this be warned we
spoil quite a bit of the Final Fantasy 7
remake and the events of the original
Final Fantasy 7 so proceed at your own
risk that said now that you finally got
your hands on the remake and slaps em
off across the face you probably know
that this isn't your mummy and daddys
Final Fantasy 7
the remake introduced some drastic
changes to the narrative the series
going forward so while we can't be sure
of what's ahead we noticed a bunch of
nods to what came 23 years ago here are
all the Easter eggs and callbacks we
found that connect the original Final
Fantasy 7 with the remake in the
original before saying the bomb in the
reactor cloud loses control of himself
as a voice tells him to watch out this
isn't just a reactor in the remake this
flashback alludes to the revelations in
the story that normally we wouldn't see
until the second or third discs in the
original for example when Jesse asks
cloud if he and teef are close we see
his childhood in nibble hime with Tifa
when Barret gets into it with the Shinra
employees on the train to sector 7 a
variation of corals theme plays we will
not submit to intimidation or violence
coral is Barrett's hometown and this is
alluding to his painful history with
Shinra corporation when they stabbed him
in the back
I knew that red hair looked familiar
Johnny can actually be found in the
original Final Fantasy 7 sector 7 slums
still holding out hope that Tifa might
notice him after all those years if you
look closely at the two pictures hanging
in the wall of tifa's bar 7th heaven you
can see and emerged how it looked in the
original version of the game pretty cool
if you complete all the side missions in
chapter 3 and take on the alone at last
quest you are invited into tifa's room
if you look next to her bed you can see
a pair of brown cowboy boots these very
closely resemble the boots she wore in
nibble hime five years earlier when she
gave cloud and Sephiroth and somebody
else I won't spoil her a tour of Mount
Nebo
when you sneak into Jesse's house in
chapter 4 if you read the letter she had
addressed to her parents she mentions
that she's landed a starring role in a
play at the gold saucer cloud then says
out loud
Jessie raspberry as the princess later
on in the original when you revisit the
gold saucer cloud is forced to join the
same play with Eris
Tifa or yuffie playing the role of the
princess the brief mechanic that has you
timing your thumbstick movements with
Barret and Tifa in the sector 5 reactor
is a direct nod to timing button presses
during the same section in the original
symmetry on a similar note sliding down
the pipes is how you reach the bottom of
the sector 5 reactor in the original as
well symmetry again when cloud meets
Aerith in the church and she mentions
the materia she keeps wrapped up in her
hair he sees a quick montage of Erath
materia dropping to the ground right
after Sephiroth kills her in the city of
the Ancients which of course is a call
back to the original cutscene it hurts
every single time just like in the
original when you're escaping Reno and
his goons in the church you can use the
environment to your advantage by
dropping things on shinra's soldiers
clouds bringing the rain indeed and
doing it the same all these years later
right after escaping the Turks with
Aerith in sector 5 slums before crossing
the rooftops she points out which
direction it is to get back to sector 7
she then asks cloud shall we mosey on
over this must be a sly nod to why cloud
might have the phrase in his head when
he says or I everyone let's mosey when
trying to inspire the party to take on
the final boss of the game in the
original
like the timed button press minigames
many of these simple gameplay moments
were brought back in some form from the
original another can be found when
Elmira asks cloud to sneak out of Eris
house late at night without telling her
in the original if you move faster than
walking speed Aerith will catch you in
the remake however it's if you knock
over some furniture you jerk
there's an item shop in wall market that
if you attempt to use fire as a machine
gun at you you may have thought is this
final fancy version of it's just a prank
bro but actually it's taken directly
from the original machine gun and all
diehard fans may also know that if you
return to this item shop in disc 2 you
can get tifa's ultimate weapon I guess
we'll find out someday if they end up
fixing the wiring and the remake any
character that completes a round in the
Coliseum will pull off a victory pose
modeled after the animations they were
given for winning a fight in the
original cloud for example spins his
sword in the air Tifa stretches Barret
cheers and arif dust down her dress very
cool while the hell house was certainly
one of the weirder random encounters in
the original it somehow makes sense that
it's here now as a frontline boss fight
all these years later I mean everyone in
the sector 5 slums would love a house so
naturally the apex predator of the area
might evolve to look like a median
income household to drag in aspiring
tenants right makes perfect sense did
you know that the side missions you
complete during the war market section
in chapter 9 are directly modeled after
the steps you had to go through to get
an outfit for cloud in the original in
order to dress up as a woman the first
time around
you had to convince the clothing store
owners drunk father to make a cloud
address and you had to compete against
the weightlifters in a squat competition
to get awake Aerith on the other hand
just grabbed the dress off a shelf easy
peasy
during the confrontation with don
cornell when at one time cloud Tifa and
Aerith all discuss perturbing threats of
the penal nature each of their lines are
actually taken from the original the
threats here as hard
today as they did then in the train
graveyard the ghoul is an all-new boss a
much like the hell house eligor is
another minor enemy encounter from the
original that's gotten the full boss
fire treatment I know about you bye
though is pretty cool leading up to the
collapse of the sector 7 play 20 phase
flying her way up the tower Reno from
his gunship lines up a shot at T foe
with the minigun at the last minute
route swerves the helicopter off balance
and Reno misses why's that you might ask
because as it's revealed during the GaN
Gaga section in the original rules been
crushing hard on Tifa during the sector
7 play collapse cutscene they briefly
show cats eff up in the Shinra building
looking devastated Reve controlling him
from afar was too late in stopping the
Turks from carrying out their mission
needless to say there is an explanation
for the angry weird blue cat we just
haven't got there yet
in the original depending on how you
treated and responded to certain
characters you would wind up on a date
with either Barret Tifa Aerith or yuffie
at the gold saucer while you don't visit
the gold saucer quite yet in the remake
the spirit of that magical night lives
on as depending on how you treat Aerith
and Tifa you're treated to a midnight
rendezvous with one of them or even
Barret the first time we visited Eris
God and we were pretty upset that they
didn't include the cover material from
the original hiding in the bottom-right
corner of a flower patch however later
on in the game you can find a pink
material orb in the same place it was in
the original pretty rad a brand new
character to the series Leslie initially
warns cloud Aerith and Tifa of the
danger that comes with interacting with
don cornell eventually it's revealed
that he possibly lost his fiancee in the
same way years before that and since
then has dedicated his life to ending
the Dawn's in the original the next time
in the story you see d'Anconia is if you
decide to visit route i is that one will
next see Leslie stay tuned kids when
ascending up the collapsed sector 7 play
in the remake the final boss of this
section is against the Valkyrie a flying
machine with dual machine guns and a
drill for above in the original you
only fight this machine in the second
half of the boss fight against the
Arsenal though it appears out of order
we're glad they brought it back in some
form just like in the original you can
either sneak into the upper levels of
Shinra HQ by taking the stairs or her
parents advice by going in gun arms
blazing too bad you don't find an Alexa
halfway up the original though the
elevator path also stops a couple of
flaws for battles just like in the
original during the guided tour of
shinra's history Barret makes a comment
about never trusting Shinra while
looking at his gun on during shinra's
attack on coral bara is shot in the hand
while trying to save dine which leads to
him getting the gun arm replacement in
the 3d visualizer seen during the Shinra
tour when the narrator is describing the
ancients you see a snippet of what could
very well be the city of ancients
resembling the seashell like design of
the original another really nice little
touch when you meet red 13 FIFA asks him
what his real name is and he puts his
head down ashamed he's become so far
removed from his life of old cloud
changes the subject but if they hadn't
quickly moved on he might have revealed
that his given name from his hometown in
Cosmo Canyon was Nanaki enjoy being
called red for the rest of the game you
goof
yet another enemy found in a random
battle has been given a makeover what
was once an enemy that could be taken
out with a couple of bolts the soda feed
now requires all five party members to
bring down it's a pretty bombastic boss
fight though gotta love it in the
original game after rescuing Aerith
you're captured by Reno and rude as you
attempt to escape Shinra HQ via the
elevator
you're then placed into jail cells to
progress the story you have to one at a
time select conversations with Erath
Tifa red 13 and Barrett while you don't
get captured this time around you are
placed into a room where Aerith grew up
and she shares a similar story about her
knowledge of the Ancients it's very much
a nod to the original scene to make it
through Hojo's research laboratory the
drum you have to make use of
communication machines scattered about
with the name PHS written on them these
allow you to take control between cloud
Bera in one section of the lab and
Aerith and Tifa in another and the
original you used the PHS device to swap
your party members in and out at save
points just like the original
Rufus fights cloud with his faithful
companion Darkstar he also exists the
fight by grabbing on to a passing
helicopter with one hand classic Rufus
am i right no literally as classic Rufus
this time around Heidegger is the one to
ask the party to identify themselves but
the results are equally hilariously
lab rat dog in the original Rufus asks
by the way just who are you and each
member of the pipes themselves it's one
of the first moments that reiterates
what a ragtag team you've established in
the remake it's limited to Barrett
Aerith and red 13 but quality over
quantity shines though at various points
during flashbacks you can see cutscenes
that are shot for shot taken from the
original or even spin-off content like
Final Fantasy Advent Children
for example media is presented with a
red sky and tornados forming above
Midgar red 13 can be found running with
two little pups by his side right as
they view Midgar taken over by greenery
cloud can be seen laying a body into a
pool of water which for the record
better be areathis where to and you can
briefly catch a glimpse of a scene that
played during the introduction to Advent
Children when Marlene recaps the game
story
it shows cloud leaping towards Sephiroth
based on how the game ends though will
any of this come to fruition in the same
way if at all who knows stay tuned kids
there you have it I'm sure we missed
quite a few references to the original
so be sure to let us know in the
comments below if you spied anything but
just do it you know politely nicely be
cool about it
chill we're all friends here anyways
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
2043 for the next episode of Final
Fantasy 7 Easter eggs maybe who knows
we'll see if you want more Final Fantasy
7 content make sure to check out games
for calm where we've got the review and
a bunch of guides and if you want to
watch videos on Final Fantasy 7 remake
well you're in the right place help our
YouTube channel where this penny
guides gameplay videos streams podcasts
pretty much anything else that has
moving pictures about Final Fantasy 7
remake enjoy have fun
[Music]